like fully sitting in the inner godhead
that everything's you there's no
separation this is this is it and
simultaneously Discerning where there's
still quote Shadow programs that are
running one of the loudest ones is just
control like control aari basically
whether it's the world economic forum
and Global elitist that are controlling
the entirety of civilization or whether
it's the controlling of minds or body
in spirituality uh from this from the
sing from sucking on the testicles and
pedestalize the godhead when you
pedestalize done deal done deal done
deal you do so you have to sit in it
yourself fully sit in it yourself and
and completely cut the Outsourcing
completely cut the Outsourcing from that
place then you can work within this
distributed network of these empty
loving pure clean mirrors that are
working together to Manifest this new
world